today I want to talk to you about
something
that really motivates me every day
and sort of guides what I work on
it inspires me
so to ground this a bit more I want to
share some observations about the
current state of software development
so this graphic you've probably already
seen before this has been standard fare
in all data science talks for the last
decade
but
this graphic is Monica regatti's data
science hierarchy of needs it does a
good job of listing a lot of the tasks
common tasks that people do in a machine
learning or data science workflow
and
one observation I want to make is we
need to write code at all stages of the
workflow
if it's doesn't matter if it's AI or
deep learning or cleaning data we end up
writing code at all these stages and
it's very writing code is Central to
everything we do but our tools of the
innovation in our tools have mostly
focused on the Outer Loop
how we write code has mostly stayed the
same for a long period of time
whereas there's been a lot of innovation
and sort of the data and compute layer
also what I call Star Ops which is like
ml Ops data Ops whatever you want to
call it you know things that help you
bring things into production there's
been a lot of uh Innovation around that
and
As you move your code into production
it's it's well known that friction
rapidly increases when it like
repackaging that code so we live in Two
Worlds
basically a lot of people start off in a
kind of a rebel or a notebook they write
code there and end up refactoring it on
the path to production but you also end
up refactoring code the other way
if you need to play with your code and
experiment with it when it's already in
production a lot of times you end up
refactoring parts of your code in a way
that you can play with it in a notebook
in a rebel again
and we live in these two like kind of
Two Worlds
and this is a well-known kind of thing
and it's something that we debate a lot
as a community to the extent where we
debate how we write code
um so you know I think kind of this is
really well illustrated by the way Joel
and Jeremy kind of debate each other I
don't like notebooks and I like
notebooks kind of two extremes on the
same spectrum of how we write code
and kind of a more recent data point is
there's this excellent study done by
Shreya Shanker and her colleagues from
UC Berkeley called operationalizing
machine learning and over over the
course of several years she canvas the
industry in collected
best practices and kind of took notes on
the things the hurdles that people faced
in their pain points in their workflow
and the thing that stuck out the most is
this contention about how we write code
particularly there was a lot of strong
opinions on Jupiter notebooks that were
wildly different
so just to highlight some anecdotes you
know so some participants preferred to
use notebooks in production and I'll
read one anecdote from from an
interviewee so we put each component of
the pipeline in a notebook which has
made life so much better now I can run
one specific component if I want not the
entire pipeline so on and so forth
and kind of an opposing anecdote that
someone else in another interviewee says
even we even went as far to
philosophically discourage the use of
notebooks in the development environment
altogether
so that's profound that's a there's a
really diverging viewpoints in applied
machine learning teams
and so this is summarized
in the paper saying that okay this kind
of conflict conflicting opinions is is a
is because of competing priorities
in those priorities they're either
moving at High Velocity or kind of
reducing bugs and things that uh where
that can be reduced by imposing more
constraints on the development
environment
so are we left with just debating this
forever are we going to be left is this
an impasse where we just have to live
with in terms of
how we write software
and I don't think so
um I want to kind of tell you about two
very interesting threads in programming
that I think are really exciting and
offer a lot of possibilities and also
show you some examples
so these two threads are literate
programming and exploratory programming
and I'll talk more about what these two
things mean in a bit
so to help
illustrate these two things I'm going to
lean on kind of two champions of these
various paradigms one is Donald knuth
for literate programming and one is
Brett Victor for exploratory programming
so I'm going to first tackle literate
programming
so literate program is an idea
that combines programming and
documentation
and the idea is that software is written
to be read by humans
and it's natural language interspersed
with code
the kind of the person who coined the
term literate programming is Donald
knuth
he's kind of most well known for his
encyclopedia on algorithms called The
Art of computer science
and that's what most people know Donald
news as but I argue a lot of people
don't know Donald knuth let me get to
that in a bit
and even if you don't know Donald knuth
he's probably touched your life in one
way or the other
if you ever done a whiteboarding
interview
algorithms interview if you've been
hazing this way
um you can almost draw a straight line
between that and this Encyclopedia of
algorithms
and it's really one of them this
Encyclopedia of algorithms is one of the
most celebrated Works in computer
science
um there's notable people in computer
science that have said really good
things like Bill Gates has said
if you're a really good programmer read
canoe's book
you should definitely send me a resume
if you can read the whole thing
Peter norvik has said the art of
computer programming is the Bible of its
field like an actual Bible it's long and
comprehensive no other book is as
comprehensive that's ridiculously high
praise
and again this is what this is what most
people know Donald knuth for uh that's
what people associate with him and it's
really interesting because they also
Associated Donald knuth with this ideal
of like rigor of computer science
but the lesser-known part of Donald
knuth is this term literate programming
and I would I would argue that dollar
knuth is even more excited about
literate programming than this
Encyclopedia of algorithms and um
there's this excellent book where he's
compiled all of his papers and all of
his talks on the subject
which I'm going to go through some uh
some excerpts in a bit so Donald knuth
actually it's really interesting to look
at the workflow of Donald knews like how
does he program what does he do
and he's actually developed his own
programming language that is a literate
programming language and that and it's
called Web
and he programs in in in one like it
generates source code from one source of
Truth
uh source code and documentation from
one source of Truth so he writes his
code in prose in one place and that
compiles to a program
and also compiles to documentation
and just to kind of walk you through a
little bit more about how important this
is
I'm going to kind of go through some hot
takes from Donald's news on literary
programming which I think are really
interesting
because they are really hot takes from
someone who is very mildly tempered
normally so
I'm just going to read these off
let us change our traditional attitude
to the construction of programs instead
of imagining that our main task is to
instruct a computer
on what to do let us concentrate on
explaining to humans what we want a
computer to do
so that should tickle your brain a
little bit explaining to humans what we
want a computer to do that ties into
some of the recent kind of AI assisted
code development which I'm gonna touch
on later
he also says by conning the phrase
literate programming I am imposing a
moral commitment on everyone who hears
the term surely no one wants to admit to
writing an illiterate program
all of the major problems associated
with computer programming are
ameliorated when programs and their
dialogues with users become more
literate
that really floored me when I heard when
I saw that I read that at least 20 times
to make sure that that was the quote
programming is best regarded as the
process of creating works of literature
which are meant to be read
and then the last quote in retrospect
the fact that illiterate program takes
much less time to debug is not
surprising because the non-literate
program encourages discipline or sorry
the literary program web encourages
discipline that was previously unwilling
to impose on myself there's actually one
more quote sorry
and that quote is he has found to a
surprise that the total time of writing
and debugging
a literate program which is his web
program is no greater than total time in
of debugging a non-literate program even
though his literate program are much
better and have substantially more
documentation
so
this is really interesting
and he's taken he lives in a different
world a different workflow that few
people experience
and I want to point out that this
literary programming Paradigm is very
experiential like you only
can understand it if you experience it
but the tragedy is that not not this web
language is not something that
is accessible to a lot of people are
practical for a lot of people to use so
not that many people have really
experienced it
and kind of can only read about it uh
you know through these works from
Donald's news
and Donald Trump news hasn't changed his
mind if you look at
recent interviews uh when Donald knuth
he goes on and on about how great
literate programming is I would say you
know that he really lights up and is
very excited when he talks about that
and so now that you understand what
literate programming is we have seen
nods to literate programming in a lot of
places so things like our markdown where
you can weave together code and prose
together
and then notebooks in general have been
a nod to literate programming things
like Matlab Jupiter Mathematica where
you can write code in prose together
but writing pros and code in in Pros
with production code is still painful so
this is psychic learn documentation
so you see the right hand side of the
slide
that's a page from psychalearn
documentation it looks like a notebook
doesn't it it has some what looks like a
cell that runs some code has some
documentation but all of this is stuffed
into a string
and that's really painful
and there's still a gap with literate
programming notebooks don't really take
you all the way you still have to
refactor your code out of the notebook
to create a program so it's not really
like anything like web
where it's a single source of truth that
generates both documentation and source
code
you know there's still a gap
so I'm going to switch gears a little
bit and talk about exploratory
programming so exploratory programming
is the idea
that you should have an immediate
connection and feedback to your code
it really focuses on interactive and
dynamic development
in the champion the best champion of
exploratory programming is Brett Victor
I would argue Brett Vector said he
wanted he wanted to make a new Matlab or
a cross between Matlab and GarageBand
um which I hope he does work on one day
so I'm going to show you so one of the
best talks on exploratory programming is
this talk from Brett Victor inventing on
principle
and that talk is very long I can't show
the whole thing but I'm going to show
you two excerpts from that talk they
really highlight why exploratory
programming is
is useful
so hopefully the sound can play
so down here I've got um I've got this
for Loop where I'm counting to 16. I'm
putting 16 little pink blossoms on every
branch and I can turn that down for Less
Blossom or turn it up for more
but look at what I'm doing here
I'm just kind of moving that number up
and down around 20 or so
and it has this really interesting
shimmering effect it kind of looks like
the the wind is blowing through the tree
and the first time I saw this I
immediately started thinking about how I
could use this effect for an animation
how would I ever have discovered that if
I had to compile and run between every
change
so much of art so much of creation is
Discovery and you can't discover
anything if you can't see what you're
doing
so that's really profound you can't it's
so much of creation is Discovery and
this exploratory programming Paradigm is
important to that here's another
demonstration where Brett victor goes
through kind of a video game demo of a
similar idea
and now I can try it
but now it's not bouncing enough
and so while it's nice that I can kind
of adjust the code while it's running
instead of having to stop and recompile
and find my place again I can't
immediately see what I need to see which
is whether or not he can make that jump
so here's what I'm going to do
I'm gonna bounce off my turtle
pause the game
and now hit this button here
which shows my guy's Trail
so now I can see where he's been
and when I rewind
this Trail in front of him is where he's
going to be this is his future
and when I change the code I change his
future
so I can find exactly the value I need
so when I hit play he slips right in
there
so yeah this is really interesting as
well
I would say a lot of hacking on machine
learning and data cleaning code feels
exactly like this doesn't it and it's
really important to that workflow and
Brad Victor just does a really good job
of explaining the concept to a much
broader audience
now that you understand a little bit
about what literate programming is and
what exploratory programming is what if
we combined the two concepts together
what would that look like
and so that's what mbdev is
mbdub is a python project that allows
you to write literate and exploratory
programs and it's kind of supercharged
with notebooks
and so what mbdev does is it extends
notebooks and it makes them overlap a
lot more with literate programming and
exploratory programming it just extends
notebooks to do a lot more
so what is mbdev
so maybe at a high level this is not an
mbdev talk and I have separate talks on
mbw I'm just going to give you a
lightning version so
mbw allows you to generate python
modules from notebooks there's a two-way
sync between your notebook and an IDE
and you have fine grain grain control on
like what cells get exported what cells
don't get exported so on and so forth
you can develop your modules directly
from notebooks you can import modules
into other notebooks
the documentation is automatically
rendered with quarto and you might
remember Corto if you're in this track
earlier today in JJ Lair who's sitting
right there demonstrated it
it's a beautiful project by the way
you can even write your read be in
notebooks
there's also unit testing framework
that works in CI and it works out of the
box
and there's facilities for python
Packaging
and so it is a system for literate
programming and exploratory programming
that is accessible to a lot more people
because it uses a very popular is for a
very popular python or sorry very
popular programming languages as python
and it just means that a lot more people
can experience what literate programming
is and what exploratory programming
really is
um so the results the
the project has enjoyed lots of
popularity
it has been used to write a
significant python projects and
libraries so fast AI
one of the most popular
high-level libraries on top of Pi torch
for deep learning was developed using
mbdev
the most popular python client for the
GitHub API called GH API is also
developed with
mbw so it's not just about data science
and deep learning it's it can be used
for kind of general purpose programming
and it's there's a lot of people that
really like mbdev this is a quote from
Chris lattner who's an inventor of Swift
and lovm
who says he really thinks mbw is a huge
step forward in programming environments
and this is kind of one anecdote
electors are out there to help
illustrate what mbw is so this is Eric
from Lyft and he says I use this mbw in
production at my company I can write
docs test and code all in one place
I get a lot of skeptical looks when I
say the source code is in notebooks but
that's just syntactic sugar for the
source code
so what are the challenges with mbdiv I
want to share like some things we
learned
so kind of three main pain points is
the source of Truth isn't plain text
it's a notebook so diffing on GitHub is
hard and that can be difficult for some
people because you can't install plugins
like NB review or something like that
uh you know not everyone can install
those plugins
also effectively a new programming
language in some sense
because it offers a new workflow you
kind of have to think about your
workflow differently
and then also it's bootstrap with
notebooks rather than being an IDE built
from the ground up so there's some rough
edges and limitations
but I think one of the things that kind
of limit mbw is we is that we get caught
up on debating about notebooks people
see the word notebooks and they debate
the word notebooks and kind of
I think that's the wrong thing to be
doing
I think we should see the forest for the
trees
so there's these Concepts that we
learned about today literary programming
exploratory programming
and literary programming exploratory
programming are not synonymous with
Jupiter notebooks
we can innovate our notebooks we can
have a new kind of notebook we can use
something else that's not notebooks we
are empowered to make tools in this
space
these ideas I think are more important
now than ever
this is a demo from Greg Brockman from
openai I don't know if maybe you've seen
this demo where he uploads a video file
into chatgpt and using kind of the alpha
plugin that has access to a python
interpreter he says can you extract the
first five seconds of video and then
charge EBT generates the python code but
also executes it
and I also see people starting to make
plugins in their notebook where they can
converse and get assistance with AI in
this kind of conversational kind of
literate exploratory mode is very
important uh and it kind of fits the ux
of this kind of AI assisted coding
and it really pushes this Paradigm
forward a bit more
so okay my call to action here is I
think there's lots of room to build
tools upon these Concepts again it's not
just notebooks I think we can think
outside the box
we don't have to get stuck in notebooks
just for analytics or notebooks just as
hosted collaborative environments
it's not only about notebooks and I
would say very few people are working on
this problem
and
yeah if this is something that interests
interests you if you're curious about
the future of mbdev or what I'm working
on what we're working on I would love to
talk to you and please give please get
in touch thank you
thank you